Transcription: Sophie Charreton
Relecteur: eric vautier
Je m’appelle Arthur
et je suis un funambule moderne.
Je marche en équilibre sur une sangle.
On appelle ça la slackline.
Quand la slackline est tendue en hauteur,
on parle de highline.
La highline, c’est difficile,
intimidant, terrifiant même.
Mais avec la pratique,
ça devient vite grisant.
La sensation d’équilibre, de contrôle,
le calme qui s’installe dans mon esprit,
c'est ça que je recherche.
C’est un moyen pour moi
de m’évader, de méditer.
J'entre dans un espace mental qui m'est
propre, qui m'apaise, qui me rend heureux.
Cet espace mental,
j’aime y rester longtemps
Et naturellement, pour y rester longtemps,
j’évolue sur des lignes longues.
Aujourd’hui, je vais vous raconter
l’histoire d’une de ces lignes,
la plus longue que j’ai pu parcourir.
La plus longue au monde.
Je vois le monde
à travers mon regard de highliner.
Quand mes yeux se sont posés
sur le col de la Croix Saint-Robert,
j’ai su que c’était l’endroit idéal
pour installer une highline hors normes.
Ce col offre
de magnifiques paysages verdoyants
et les deux sommets qui le bordent,
le puy de l’Angle et le roc de Cuzeau,
culminent à la même altitude
et sont distants de 2710 mètres.
2710 mètres.
Une distance immense, improbable,
ambitieuse, mais je le sais, réalisable.
Nous sommes en septembre 2020
et l’idée se grave dans ma tête.
Petit à petit, je me renseigne,
je m’entoure,
et l’idée devient un vrai projet.
Deux ans s'écoulent.
Le projet 2700, comme je l’ai appelé,
est devenu une réalité.
Nous sommes le 1er août 2022.
Il est 19h et enfin, la ligne est là,
tendue devant moi.
Elle est prête.
Elle m'attend.
Je m’isole, je retire
mes chaussures, mes chaussettes.
Je marche pieds nus dans l'herbe,
ça m'aide à me détendre.
Je m'échauffe les épaules et il est temps.
Je monte sur la ligne.
J’exécute les mouvements
parfaitement ancrés
dans ma mémoire musculaire
et je suis assis sur la ligne.
Je respire encore quelques instants,
et je me lance.
Je transfère du poids sur mes pieds
et doucement, je me lève.
Je commence à marcher.
Immédiatement, la difficulté me frappe.
Je dois lutter pour chaque pas,
pour chaque mètre.
Au bout de dix minutes,
j’ai parcouru seulement 200 mètres
et je suis déjà fatigué.
A ce rythme, les 2500 mètres restants
vont demander trop de temps et d’énergie.
Je risque l'épuisement, l'évanouissement.
Je prends ma décision.
Je m'arrête.
Je m'assois de nouveau sur la ligne.
Immédiatement,
un sentiment de soulagement m’envahit.
Je sais que j'ai pris la bonne décision.
Beaucoup plus détendu,
je fais demi-tour
et je rentre à l’ancrage.
Bredouille, mais heureux malgré tout.
Nous sommes là pour deux semaines.
Il y aura d'autres tentatives.
Sur la ligne, le funambule évolue seul.
Mais autour, nous sommes 25.
25 passionnés.
Nous venons d'un peu partout en France,
mais aussi d'Italie, de Roumanie,
d’Allemagne, de Belgique,
du Canada et des États-Unis.
Chacun est essentiel et nous le savons.
Nous sommes une équipe soudée,
réunie autour d’un but unique :
profiter au maximum
de cette ligne exceptionnelle.
Chacun a ses ambitions personnelles,
mais c’est bien un effort collectif
qui est nécessaire
pour que tout fonctionne.
J’ai ouvert le bal sur la ligne
et rapidement,
les autres membres de l’équipe
me rejoignent.
Le matin du 2 août,
nous retendons la ligne
et à la faveur de vents favorables,
Augustin prend pied sur le puy de l’Angle
après avoir traversé
toute la ligne sans tomber.
Cette performance constitue
le nouveau record du monde.
Pour Augustin et pour le groupe,
c'est la consécration.
Le projet est un succès.
A partir de maintenant,
tout ce qui se passe fait du projet
un succès encore plus grand.
Les doutes, les incertitudes sont balayés.
La traversée sans tomber,
le send, est possible.
Le lendemain matin,
Tania réussit le second send.
Et au fond de moi,
je sais que je peux y arriver aussi.
Et le 4 août, c'est de nouveau mon tour.
C’est une matinée d’été calme,
comme tant d’autres,
avec un temps magnifique.
A 8h et dix minutes,
je m’élance à nouveau.
Cette fois,
l’équilibre est bien plus simple à tenir.
La météo est idéale,
mon état d’esprit excellent.
J’atteins rapidement l’état de flow,
une sorte de transe,
une bulle mentale qui transforme le stress
en énergie, en apaisement, en confiance.
Je marche en rythme,
avec douceur et précision.
Je suis lucide, concentré,
méthodique, déterminé.
Depuis des mois,
je suis sur tous les fronts
pour tout organiser.
Mais je n'y pense pas.
Je ne pense pas non plus
au record du monde.
J’ai une seule chose en tête :
rester debout.
Mon corps entier s’y emploie.
En mode automatique,
il sait ce qu’il a à faire.
Effleurer la sangle avec l'orteil.
Aligner le pied, le poser,
le charger, recommencer.
Le même geste technique, fin, délicat
à réussir 7000 fois de suite,
les yeux rivés sur la sangle,
30 mètres en avant,
sans faillir pendant près de 2 h.
C’est ma seconde traversée et,
je le sais, certainement la dernière.
Nous démonterons la ligne l’après-midi
pour éviter de l’exposer aux vents
violents et aux orages qui sont annoncés.
Elle sera peut-être remontée ensuite,
mais c’est incertain.
Et si c’est le cas,
je laisserai les autres en profiter.
Ils le méritent.
Tout en gardant mon objectif en tête,
je grave les sensations dans ma mémoire.
Le vent léger et constant
qui facilite ma tâche,
les petits déséquilibres,
la texture de chaque section de sangle.
J'ai la certitude que je vais y arriver.
Je constate, amusé comme à chaque fois,
l'absurdité de la situation.
Je suis en train de marcher dans le ciel.
Il n’y a rien à 150 mètres
dans toutes les directions,
à gauche, à droite, en haut,
en bas, derrière, devant...
Seulement moi et la highline.
La ligne est composée
de sept sections de sangles différentes.
Cela nous permet de nous orienter,
de connaître la distance parcourue.
J'atteins la sangle orange.
C'est la dernière.
Il reste 500 mètres.
J’en ai parcouru 2200
et je me sens arriver.
Devant moi, l’ancrage,
la ligne d’arrivée, m’attire.
Et machinalement, j’accélère.
Je connais cette sensation.
Je sais qu'il est possible de tomber.
Je dois rester concentré.
Je me force à ralentir.
« Allez Arthur, encore 20 minutes
et ce sera fait. »
A voix haute, je m'encourage.
« Tranquille. Calme. Allez,
ça va le faire. Patience. »
Je sais que j'ai bien géré ma traversée.
Mes épaules sont détendues
et mes pieds pas trop douloureux,
même après 1h et demie d’efforts.
Les quelques randonneurs curieux
ne sont plus des points lointains,
mais des silhouettes bien définies.
La sangle défile sous mes pieds.
Je suis proche.
Je reconnais mes amis.
Je sais que les derniers mètres
peuvent être traîtres,
mais je suis préparé.
Je sais ce que j'ai à faire.
J'entre dans les 20 derniers mètres.
Il est convenu que,
une fois cette zone atteinte,
le record est validé.
Si je chute,
je toucherai le sol avant d’être retenu
par ma longe de sécurité.
Et c’est un risque
que j’ai le choix de ne pas prendre.
Je profite encore
de quelques derniers pas.
Je retire mon chapeau
pour saluer le public
et je saisis la sangle à pleines mains.
J’ai réussi. J’exulte.
Au total, nous sommes huit
à partager le record.
Dix autres ont réussi à traverser
en chutant une ou plusieurs fois.
Ce bilan est exceptionnel.
C'est du jamais vu dans notre milieu.
Je suis fier de détenir le record,
mais ce n’est qu’une petite partie,
une brique dans l’aventure collective
que représente ce projet.
La vraie fierté, le vrai accomplissement,
c’est la transformation d’une idée absurde
dans la tête d’une personne,
en réalité dans les mains de 25 personnes.
Nous avons réussi ensemble.
Le groupe a accompli son objectif.
Personne n'a gagné ou perdu.
Aujourd’hui, le projet est devenu
un souvenir puissant,
gravé dans la mémoire de chacun.
Nous sommes les marcheurs de ciel.
Et peu importe
ce que l’avenir nous réserve,
nous le serons toujours.
(Applaudissements)